[Music]
i mean
bro here's what we
so you know shout out to this boy who
tweeted you know he tweeted at me
love you dog but you were kind of wrong
about that whole thing
which first of all i technically wasn't
because i said someone was going to win
yeah exactly we were we nailed it yeah
yeah i think we're actually 100 correct
and that someone won yeah but i don't
know
you know i think everyone else
felt wanted to believe but we didn't
listen to our own advice because
after the last fight we were both
talking we said nah he's just going to
pick cans and
it's just all going to be for play like
we'll just keep paying
or you know wasting time to see if it'll
happen
but it's never going to happen because
he's never ever going to pick someone
like right now he's saying like oh
tommy fury and whatever he's not going
to fight tommy fury
[ __ ] no absolutely not he's not going
gonna fight that guy
i mean if he if he if he did though it
would be a nice little like love island
oh yeah we could we could have some fun
with that one no it would
i mean jake is doing what other fighters
do
in their amateur careers is they get
their records padded by
you know beating up guys or because
you're getting experience in the ring
right but it's crazy to think that
his first fight was with um deji
and that was like an appropriate matchup
yeah they both had limited training
they're both kind of young
and he got worked yeah and i and
i think jake has proven that he has
knockout power which is
a lot to prove but when ben would get
close to him
he kind of seemed to panic a little bit
like i'm still not believing that
you know he's like uh
competent yeah actually you know what i
take it back he's really good
he's so good i think he is
actually he could fight anyone are you
just saying this so that you get it
right next time if he went
no no no i'm saying this because i think
you know and i'm gonna bump this um i
actually think jake paul has proven
i take back everything i just said i
think jake paul has proven he's the best
boxer on earth
why i think i mean he he could fight
literally anyone
why are you why are you saying this uh
because i think the fight to make
is him and brandon lee
oh that's the guy that you usually have
just yeah just just just pull up brandon
lee
i think this is the only this is
actually jake paul's only chance at
competition okay i think jake paul would
literally walk through any human on this
earth okay yeah
any weight class any anything i mean
he's quite possibly
the best boxer made by god
i think i think i would say he's the
most naturally talented
and the hardest training boxer as well
yeah probably trains harder than anyone
anyone and so that's why this fight
should be the next one
what is this this is wait just play that
real quick
let's just get a little little uh
comedic intermission here
yeah yeah
[Music]
that's scary that's scaring me
that bag weighs 200 pounds by the way
that dude is literally thrashing
concrete
[Laughter]
yeah that's scary so that's okay now
wait why are you and why did you bring
this up because he because he
said he would pay to fight jake paul oh
he really so i think we need to start a
gofundme
for to to jumpstart brandon lee's
[ __ ] um you know entry fee to compete
with jake paul because you know
jake paul only does it for the money
right that's really the only way to get
his attention so you know
which i think is fair because he is the
greatest boxer on earth yeah so
it's only right that a guy like brandon
lee has to pay yeah to fight jake paul
okay i see now if you got to take a
guess
how many fights do you think brandon's
been in just a as a professional
12. um and how many of those would you
say do you think he's one
12. he's 22-0 okay wow
so this is a scary [ __ ] yeah go
go to his page
i'm like how have i never heard of this
guy scroll down
look at um
keep going keep going oh is it going to
do the thing or it makes you
go down a little bit more a little bit
more a little bit more
i think it's that clip where the
referee's in blue
this is a great clip because if open it
in a private tab this is a great clip
because you can actually see what
happens
okay you know i'm just doing this in
case someone from triller's watching
this is how
you can actually see a boxing match it's
pretty interesting okay
and only 21 years of age with a 90
knockout percentage 90 percent there's
an overhand right
and later oh right cross followed by a
left hook and now
lee's confidence is starting to grow and
this one is
just says and i'm a little no more over
you can stop it here the ref just says
no more
he ends the fight like he ends the fight
he just waves it off he's like no this
is done
because this key just knows this kid is
like he landed like six in a row the two
just like
it's like when you're five years old and
you have a balloon and wrapped around
your hand and you're just sucking the
[ __ ] out of that thing
this dude is [ __ ] frightening man so
yeah you know
i think really he's the only he's the
only one worthy of jake paul's time
well i think i think in a video or
something like that jake paul said he's
the future he said the future of boxing
is here
oh he's right he's 100 correct and so
well
yeah i'm just saying like there has to
be there can only be one
future of boxing probably yeah so it
might they might you know they should
they might as well like
duke it out and see who's it who is it
it's gonna be you know yeah no i
definitely agree with that
um yeah poor band man
this is also great like look at how like
janky this uh
post fight interview fight interview
play this crash it's so
weird okay let me know when you're ready
let me know when you're ready
then i'll get the first question in it's
from
[Music]
donut corby okay you can pause it i
don't know
yeah it's just like yeah all right ben
it's he's just like you're tuned into a
zoom for the post fight yeah
they didn't think through anything man
so yeah you know it's only
what they made they made 70 million
dollars though
1.3 million dollar pay-per-view buys of
that and so which
equals 72 million or something like that
sorry i forgot the most important part
which how could we forget the most
important part was all the budget put
towards the fireworks show for after
jake paul won yeah yeah that was the
most important part
to make sure they had uh a literal
battleship load of fireworks ready i'm
surprised the whole [ __ ] place didn't
light on fire honestly for how much like
preparation they put into the actual
boxing part
you can imagine they didn't do any
planning as far as like fireproofing
no no no
they just sent that [ __ ] into the air i
was crying at all those memes like
like jordan like hugging like his trophy
and like crying at me like
jake paul after he beats up a cashier
like
you know like that's jake paul's next
fight is like a
like a part-time like high school
cafeteria guy
yeah who boxes in his spare time
like jake's literally going on a
campaign and fighting the most
you know um challenging opponents
ever yeah you know so sorry
tommy fury would be a real thing though
right i think he'd [ __ ] bricks if he
fought tommy fury
what i'm saying like that would be a
real fight that would be it would be a
real [ __ ] that one it would be a real
one
i honestly feel it it's someone who has
to be
quick yeah i i don't like i
i rewatched the fight three times
you did yeah okay this is like because
it's like 20 seconds long
yeah and i'm just like what what like
like i
i watched it back because i'm like all
right i don't really remember what
happened other than
ben askren got knocked out it's like
what the [ __ ] happened when you look at
it like
jake did what he was supposed to do like
ben
didn't ben gave him all the looks that
should say
i'ma knock this dude the [ __ ] out you
know like
ben wasn't even really covering yeah you
know like
jake threw out that jab and ben's hands
just stayed in the same place
so it was almost like ben was or jake
was just like punching around
[ __ ] you get what i'm saying yeah like
it wasn't like ben was like
cover cover dip dip so why wouldn't jake
win
so he did what he was supposed to do but
i don't think
you know there's that much there in
terms of like the speed because like he
he did a shot to the body that looked
like me hitting pads
i'm like you should be a lot faster than
me ben
no [ __ ] jason oh i see he hit him
with a shot to the body i don't know his
feet
i can't tell the angle was so [ __ ] yeah
maybe his feet were
positioned horribly but i don't know
yeah i rewatched it i'm like i just hate
that this kid is like
acting like you know he just won like
game seven of some [ __ ] yeah
it's like bro you just beat up an old
man
and uh yeah it's funny there's so much
smoke after the fireworks at the end
it's like i could have swear
you know snoop's around
[Laughter]
snoop must be here snoop
we've been getting a fireworks show all
night up here because of snoop's weed
did ben askren just get knocked out by
jake paul or did i have too much of
snoop's weed
happy 420 by the way dude kind of which
one yeah conor guards by the way yeah
kind regards happy 420s
to meet you by the way dude kind of
regards have a nice day
yeah best we even got a green you guys
can't see but we even got a green moon
out there on the horizon
yeah we got to get a wider shot of the
whole ship because look at that wait
there's
a third window yeah we've got three
windows here this is
like almost an observation deck it is
actually it's a really nice part of the
ship yeah it's
beautiful